arguably the biggest political question
right now in republican world is
will the trump people abandon trump once
and for all because of the fbi search
warrant served at mar-a-lago um there's
the trump legality question of course
which is is he going to get charged is
he going to jail or whatever
um
will he be eligible to run in 2024 but
then there's the would people vote for
him and one of the things that we
learned
is that these maga people
many of whom were never involved in
politics pre-trump
may or may not remain involved in
politics once trump is no longer the
person involved in politics and
you know we maybe have one more election
cycle where where trump will be involved
and so it was with great interest that i
awaited seeing some of exactly these
interviews and clips that we're going to
play for you today
which is
your random maggots
reacting to the fbi search warrant and
unfortunately it's scary and it's insane
this is not merely disaster porn
although it is
it's also about
is there anything for which they would
abandon donald trump now there's been
the infamous i could shoot someone on
fifth avenue and people would still vote
for me and that may be the case and
compared to that this seems relatively
benign in some sense so let's go right
into some of these clips here's one guy
saying this is another bunch of rigor
morse rigor morse all about jealousy is
be honest robert tassie shared the same
sentiment have you seen the documents to
prove it on a reasonable doubt that
these deaths is a true statement it was
another political bunch of
rigor morse to make him look even worse
now aside from the fact that rigor morse
is not a word maybe he meant
maybe he went some kind of rigor mortis
morse code the sort of morse code of a
dying political dynasty i i don't know
i'm i'm just kidding i don't know what
this guy's talking about but
there is a level of
skepticism that these folks apply
to any criticism of their beloved orange
leader
that they don't apply elsewhere
and he can say anything and they will
defend him and indeed that seems to be
the case here fox news to their credit
they went down to mar-a-lago and they
interviewed protesters and people who
were out rallying for trump and whatever
else
and um it's it's really scary it's quite
frankly it's we have a crisis of
critical thinking in this country take a
look at this what is your view on the
fbi and why they decided to raid uh the
former president's property i think
they're just a mafia you know being uh
ordered by ray an app yeah
it's a mafia ordered by rey ray being
the fbi director
who was chosen by donald trump
and who donald trump expressed unending
confidence in
that's the guy who's running the mafia
tyrae and after this man
our ex-president for so long they're
trying to find any kind of dirt they can
pull up on him this is insane
i never see this happening when i stay
by then has to go to jail
hunter is the one fbi has to go and get
it yeah hunter
go and get hunter now what does hunter
have that the fbi would need to recover
via search warrant i'm not aware of
anything whatsoever and so there's a
combination here of unending devotion to
the cult leader there's what about ism
and we've seen the what about ism has
been heavy what about hillary clinton
well benghazi was investigated
the email stuff was investigated we know
exactly why she wasn't charged with
benghazi she sat under oath and
testified for eight hours there were 11
investigations i believe the number is
these things are
completely and totally different there
is no similarity hunter biden what on
earth does hunter biden have to do with
any of this and then of course they talk
about obama what i don't
obama what obama gate they say but they
can't even explain what that is one more
of these clips this is also fox news
speaking to more people
about uh
the search warrant and everybody's as
confused as you could imagine and that's
basically i mean it's been going on now
for over six years ever since he came
down the escalator they've been after
him
by the way this entire down the
escalator
trump has started using it as a sort of
nostalgic phrase from the moment i came
down the escalator with our beautiful
first lady
uh they've been going after me
that's the thing
now his followers his sycophantic
followers have started to repeat the
whole down the escalator what they the
full story would be
ever since trump came down the escalator
and suggested most mexicans coming over
to the u.s are murderers and rapists
it's been xyz they'll never mention that
extra little part yesterday was the
ultimate we've never seen anything like
that my life i believe that they're
trying to make it so he cannot run i
think they're trying to attack the
american people and they're trying to go
after the person who put us first and
put our american godly values first that
we know what's funny about that put us
first and put godly values first let's
deal with them one by one in terms of
godly first trump's not religious trump
has never been religious trump doesn't
have any spiritual beliefs it was all a
sham just like his supposedly
anti-abortion stance this was all
contrived and fabricated in order to
justify himself as a candidate for the
republican nomination
because the democratic primary uh
electorate would never have fallen for
trump in the first place bottom line
trump's not religious and you can look
at what's your favorite bible verse well
that's very personal and when he talked
about two corinthians as if they walk
into a bar
uh all it he's not religious but these
folks think this is a godly man but more
importantly he put us first and there's
almost a twinge of sadness with that and
the reason i say sadness is
these people are so duped
trump has spent his entire life as a
privileged rich kid from queens who grew
up in manhattan or from manhattan who
grew up in queens whatever queen's
manhattan
he's been trying to insulate himself
from these folks his entire life
the people that donated the money to him
the people that put him in the white
house
these aren't people that he actually
likes and as we've seen
he only even tolerates them to the
extent that they're useful to him either
financially or more recently in his
political career when they're useful
politically but they've been duped
they've fallen for it it's really
something else godly values first that's
why i believe they're going after him to
intimidate us as americans
okay
in all seriousness
i don't know that even this is enough
for the maggots to bail
it seems that the weekend saw
kind of like a little bit shakier
support and i had the sense come monday
come today
they'll be united they'll either be
united behind trump or united in
abandoning trump
it's still not clear that it's all kind
of shaken out
but they have a perfect way to cut ties
with him they could even say and try to
maintain some credibility
we loved his platform in 2016.
he did good things in 2016.
we voted for him in 2020. we even think
he won in 2020 repeat the big lie
but at this point he has become
politically toxic and the republican
party needs to go in a different
direction they don't even really have to
criticize him they have an off-ramp
it doesn't seem as though the magats are
actually willing and ready i'm seeing
hunter this
hillary that obama this and the other
thing
but trump's godly and he's great and all
this different stuff to their own uh to
their own detriment at this point in
time